you're beautiful Lisa yeah given all the
information he's on top of [__] flying
to you what are you I have like 20 I
like 20 minutes left of that so ask any
questions you want now after that's not
gonna at least ready to blast off to
another dimension yeah that's crazy I'm
talking dog I'm telling you we I'm I'm
breaking out hash back out yeah you're
bringing it back we're gonna cut a
little weed down okay smoke a little bit
more Ash out of the glass I'm gonna get
a wooden pipe
we're gonna old school this I have
friends that have great [__] hash and
again I was forgetting I was sprinkling
it on marijuana and it's really like
it's like putting uh it's like putting
bacon on a [__] good cheeseburger
sometimes I thought you didn't like
bacon and cheeseburgers no I don't
that's what I'm saying it's like a
hypochondrion what do you call that [__]
when you put two of the same things on
the same [__] thing yeah yeah so I
think it's like vodka and Red Bull yeah
you know like it just but it got hit
right if you really think about it one
side Mellows you on the other side keeps
you [__] awake speedball yeah but
it's like a Puerto Rican speed ball
there's no speed ball involved after
three minutes you're looking at the Bro
going my dick is ready to rock you know
what I'm saying yeah if that's a real
speed ball your dick is deader than
disco oh [__] yeah that thing is gone
you're gone inside you what's going on
deemed out right man I am good to see
you so happy to be here it's uh it's my
favorite come down here your new studio
let me tell you something I do all my
podcasts at my house and uh it's like a
rock museum but I moved to a new place
and it's not set up yet so I come in
here and it's just got this Vibe you
know I just love it and you know what I
loved about it when we were in here
we're playing some music records it
reminded me of just being in a a buddy's
room with the bong out and his mom would
be in the other in the living room
watching soaps you know we're in there
just listening to Boston with the
blacklight posters and the weed and the
[__] and just rocked talk you know
like listen to that Mead you know
because this reminds me that do you guys
have cool rooms at kids like my mom was
so I was like she was strict and I was
just a vanilla kid so it never I never
really decorated it but like having a
bong or some black lights or something
yeah vinyl po like that must have been
fine I had all the kiss posters and that
David Lee Roth one where he's tied up on
a chain from Women and Children First
yeah that one boy that one hung up there
and uh and the kiss one where they're
dressed as Army got the you know with
the drums and the the battle wounds the
U.S army all those man another Joey Diaz
story people don't know about
so my mom bought a home in North Bergen
it was a three bedroom home but the
problem was one of the bedrooms was a
converted attic yeah that to any of us
we would jerk off all over it yeah I
didn't like it it scared me I heard mice
up there oh yeah addicts are [__]
scared I would go down to this one in
the bedroom the the there was a bedroom
with a my mom's bedroom was a master
bedroom I had the bidet the shower the
tub the [__] the window the whole
[__] thing nice two sinks and then I
had a bathroom in the hallway but the
the bedroom I moved into whoever had the
house before it was a girl's room
Pink Carpet mirrors everywhere Barbie
room you know how many times people
walked in my uh a room and walked into
the mirror because that mirror was it
looked like a huge room you kept The
Pink Carpet I kept The Pink Carpet I put
like a little wolf on the on the floor
like this dead wolf that was like oh
somebody gave me like a fur and I put
like I had the stereo with the speakers
who I robbed from the kid across the
street but then I became friends of them
and he wasn't allowed in my upstairs
like he would come to the living room
let's go upstairs into music now we
can't go upstairs my mom don't let Boys
in my room you got the speakers up there
yeah the speakers in the stereo up there
I had like a I had a Jimmy I had a Led
Zeppelin poster
that Ray Canela the guy who calls in
here for the podcast that called a
couple weeks ago he
has Led Zeppelin on stage but it was
shot backwards oh yeah of the street was
that it was a collected as item and all
this [__] I had a picture of Julius
Irving
that long one oh yeah remember that one
a long one there's this Converse right
there there's ribs yeah yeah and he was
still playing he played for the Sixers
but at that time they didn't pay the
sixes so it was like a generic costume
but he had to wear like they took the
sixes off the poster for the poster
hilarious and then I had the McDonald's
All-American basketball team
and I just on the floor next to this
thing I had to stack of albums yeah and
what you know what what album I still
had in there I still remember having the
Beach Boys oh yeah which one
round round get around yeah I get around
here right around that one I still
remember some of my first 20 [__]
albums yeah like the first five or six
albums were very confusing albums I was
still in the grabs uh I totally had
joked that they were somebody me and
Steve Simone you know Richard Richard
Pryor was basically the first album I
bought like uh right I don't know if
it's is It Something I Said or the
nigga's crazy right but when he sees
that he sees Jesus I knew Jesus I met
him on the railroad death pole I told
him don't go down there messing with
them Jews without no money you know I
forgot all about that ride and [__] I
had that one in Bicentennial [__] oh
yeah and I had them hidden yeah oh yeah
because they had to be hidden and then I
had I remember having the Beatles White
Album I had the Beatles Help yeah
and uh
okay I was like a Michael Jackson dude
yeah yeah so I had the last two Jackson
albums moving violation and the best of
Michael Jackson Who
Miss Pat argued with me at that album
didn't exist well the one with like the
bird on the cover pitching on the cover
he still has the nose he still has the
black nose that's a great [__]
greatest hits album I still remember all
these albums I I that room was uh and I
was telling Lee that what I would do is
at night I'd play records in my [__]
bedroom but in the daytime I had a
little window I could play him on my
mom's living room stereo which is kick
ass it was one of those old school box
victrolas with the oh yeah turntable the
control on the other side of the TV in
the middle yeah remember that like it's
it's like an all one piece fast
furniture guys one [__] piece of
furniture like this table yeah this is
how long it was yeah
are you serious so it went from here to
there okay and it went against the wall
so on that side was the turntable yep on
this side was the control for the radio
also yeah the turntable and eight-track
player and then the TV was in the Middle
where that thing is that Kevin put on
there I guarantee those things still
work oh yeah oh yeah those things will
work to the [__] end of time and I
know people who have them I guarantee if
you go on eBay oh yeah they're out there
you know garage sales they're out there
yeah and you're absolutely right you put
a needle from today on there and it's
brand new brand [__] new yeah you
know I saw a guy Joey he did something
that was so amazing he bought one of
those and he gutted it out and then he
put high-end stuff in there so when you
looked at it it was straight 70s but
then when you opened it up it was just
all this great equipment now it was
awesome man like just rebuilt the
insides with new [__] it was killer
Jesus I just remember that's so sad and
it was so sad to me
for a long time talking about turntables
so
the kid's name was Renee Renee was
Puerto Rican and when he was moving into
the building when he was moving into the
apartment the house yeah he went to pick
up more stuff and wherever they were
moving from and we robbed the house
mid move Rob so Renee and his dad and
the mother moved out of there they were
like running from credit creditors and
stuff
but for some reason
stereo was [__] weird like the stereo
was just old to me like I was like I
don't want to stare anymore I need some
help to get the chicks up here and to be
the cool guy on the Block I and on the
corner
was this place on four five corners it's
still there uh an appliance place yeah
and the word on the street was you could
go in there and get a fish or stereo
I think your hands on something
I got my hands oh that's
which in the day a fish is Stereo League
was like [__] tremendous this is
before blaupunk yeah people started
saying oh you have a Fisher I have a
blob punk I buy components man remember
because everybody got real cool after a
while yeah component what happened was
and this is why I don't like a cell
phone with a camera and all this [__] on
it because once the camera breaks you
got no phone for some people they can't
live without a [__] uh camera on the
phone I come old school okay I come from
the thing that once your 8-track broke
yeah the whole stereo had to get thrown
out because it was connected to the
[__] CD and the cassette play yeah so
here you were with 90 [__] eight
tracks what the [__] are you gonna do
now the eight track is broken okay now I
gotta buy albums I got the Allman
Brothers live from the Fillmore East
Side they track and I Gotta Buy [__]
albums so I said enough is enough
so I went down to [__] uh Fisher
whatever that was called and you gave
him 50 bucks down and the whole thing
came out to like 480 and those days Lee
480 dollars for a 15 for a 13 year old
kid 14 year old kid
it was like a thousand bucks 1200 bucks
thirteen fifteen hundred bucks yeah it's
the first stereo too for something for
school and I went and I financed it yeah
when I hit the number I paid it all off
oh wait they let a 12 year old kid
Finance on the coastline oh okay my mom
had a cosigner your mom has the
co-signing [__] but at least you made
payments
book they gave you a payment book yeah
and you had to walk down there every
Friday and pay the fifteen dollars like
a man
you know and you felt good like this was
my [__] stereo man like this was it
like I took care of this I dusted it I
cleaned the needle like this was [__]
it you know and when my mom died I never
took that stereo oh but that stereo sat
in that [__] room God knows what that
stero is today it broke my heart because
I had to take them you know when you
have it tuned for you like you buy a
turntable after years through the
turntable gets to see your your style
and how you drop the record and you
learn and you get the needle right and
it's uh it was a sad it was sad thing in
my life for like three years not having
that turntable but you know my my uh
best friend they had the Marantz and I
told Marin this story and it was
basically the blue collar Macintosh like
Macintosh was so much money but the
Marantz and and my buddy's dad bought it
and he had the Marantz 2275 and and a
turntable a Pioneer turntable and these
speakers and we play Highway to Hell on
it and a couple years back I bought a
Marantz 2275 and it's in my house and
and it and and I always tell people they
go does what sounds good and I go
whatever your ears grew up on
like you know because your ears grew up
on a sound and that's the sound your
brain remembers forever so when I hooked
this whole thing up and I put on you
know a record I was like that's that's
it that's eighth grade right there
Marantz yeah man and he had the blue
lighting and and the and the Marantz had
the a weighted wheel for the tuner you
just hit it it would go
you know on a ball bearing and that was
like Pro the other ones you had to turn
and they're all funky this one just hit
the the wheel and it just
you and man I got it now in my house it
is weird to describe you know I became
nerdish
about it that I was even buying
magazines you know me a long time I
don't buy magazines yeah I was buying
stereo magazines Hi-Fi Max funny I was
watching vinyl yeah on HBO how is it
vinyl is an interesting show okay it's
interesting show uh this week they had
like a slime the Family Stone type
[__] I saw the picture edible
and [__] you know yeah uh if you like
music and you like doing blow you know
and all that craziness this is the show
for you you know it's it's just I watch
it and sometimes I go what the [__] am I
watching yeah but it's entertaining you
know it's entertaining for [__] like me
because it's me it's my time I was a kid
all that last week they sang a song on
there two weeks ago that killed me
chick that [__] nice to self
with the pills with the brothers Amy
Winehouse no no Amy Winehouse this is
the [__] they started I'm sorry oh oh
so they're doing real bands
it's like uh like stories of real stuff
going on it's really weird like the
first episode is him going into having
to talk to the Led Zeppelin okay and
Peter Grant is yelling at him and wow is
he selling the record label to the
Germans yeah what the second episode the
Germans in the room and Peter Grant
walks in and he goes just let you know
I'm not selling I'm not I'm leaving you
guys I'm not going to be I'm not working
with Germans yeah wow I don't work with
[__] Germans they got a guy playing
uh Peter Graham yeah but uh he's not
really six foot six 300. he's a little
short and he talks a lot he tries to
redo that scene from
you know it's uh somebody asked me how
that scam worked yeah you know in the
70s
this is the most interesting thing I
ever read in my life I had these FBI
files from the 70s when I was on the
road in the early 98s and 99 I had an
FBI buddy yeah who gave me these files
because I told them that they were doing
a lot of mafia movies and he goes take
these and do the research
and I can't remember the guy's name
right now
okay this is how [__] Lee's Joe's
gonna drop yeah yeah and every this guy
was a well-known heroin sound wow but if
you looked at this guy he was a
businessman yep you know he was the
business end of it no flash no nothing
but uh he was a Gambino captain that
reported straight to Castellano like
Eden talked to nobody like that's how
much money he was robbing okay when
you're robbing that type of money
but his cover was he was on the board of
directors of a supermarket chain in New
York
and what they would basically do is
let's say there was
90 of these supermarkets all over New
York and the five boroughs in
Connecticut
Lee they went to each supermarket and
built an aisle I told you about this
they built an aisle like in the express
line yeah that went right to them wow
like this years later the general
manager goes every store in the country
has 10 hours every store here has 11.
why is that
so the 10 registers they were giving but
the one register was going right to this
guy that's the payoff he had 90 stores
going
an entire register can you imagine what
he got like Thanksgiving July 4 000 a
day there's 90 of them yeah yeah it's 90
of them a day I'd say you paid 300 for
somebody to make the move and pay you
that money every [__] day
what do you give a [__] yeah [__] yeah
so what they were doing in the garden
was the mob was yeah yeah Led Zeppelin
had their people but what's Peter Grant
gonna walk on every floor of the garden
and everything right so let me just put
upstairs yeah yeah in the garden yeah
because they still have that now like
whenever I go to a game or a concert
they have people with bootleg t-shirts
outside yeah but I can't imagine them
inside the venue yeah but this was the
mob itself at the Garden this was the
union it's all Union it's all unions the
green coats so the union would say Lee
do me a favor come here listen I'm gonna
give you 20 t-shirts
someone for 10 bucks you get three
dollars a t-shirt
yes sell them until somebody comes and
gets you
yeah some who gives a [__]
at a table like in like when you're
walking around like yeah in there he had
they had him in there in the [__]
living mine outside that was a complete
different operation yeah that's somebody
else this is the one inside this is the
one inside inside like the actual like
yeah so finally you know Led Zeppelin
would do five nights at the Garden
finally after the third night
you would go up to Lena Lee who's the
Italian looking guy yeah
with the stand with programs and [__]
people he's not our guy he's not one of
us yeah
oh my god so let's say I cut a deal with
Peter Grant and said well listen we're
going to have one's concession stand and
that 30 goes to the Garden yeah I told
him about three I'm gonna have 15 of
them yeah
and the band wouldn't know the band's
busy playing yeah and also they didn't
have big entourage it'd be like six guys
working with them you know they're not
combing the hole so that was just
another way so that's the scene and the
song means the saying that we're talking
about at Peter Grant is going off on the
union guys going there nobody knows what
the [__] is going on it's all stolen
it's amazing how smart criminals are
[__] opening up a bootleg
stand it like it's amazing that they
could even think who would [__] think
to question it
imagine how much they were making on
stuff like um like the Ringling Brothers
uh circus at everything yeah yeah
until you get caught did they do like
the Knicks too every event you get
caught no well the Knicks are that is
yeah yeah that's that the Knicks are
in-house they're not gonna Rob
themselves oh okay you know what I'm
saying they're gonna Rob the least
events that come in like the current
events like my wife works at the
Hollywood Bowl they book it and then
there's a promoter who books 50 of them
they they can't get you tickets they got
nothing to do with it they get a check
yeah they can negotiate a friend fee and
they sell t-shirts and sodas and beers
and they keep that but the rest goes to
the [__] dude
[__] awesome how many of these scams are
just in everyday businesses that we're
like unaware of
well I'll tell you what this is
something crazy man I I go to the wheel
turn a lot and it's over in uh over
there in uh Korea Town bless you
and
These Guys these Bootlegger guys they
don't they don't even they're not even
afraid anymore it used to be they'd be
like five blocks away they're right at
the front door when you come out now and
I'm like what's going on like these guys
don't get arrested there's cops
everywhere and everything and they're
just like nah they pay someone off you
know what I mean well like I said though
excuse me I'm very sorry I got allergies
they're very they keep doing it until
they get caught so let's say
Ringling Brothers and Barnum and Bailey
they do a three [__] nightstand that
they're good yeah okay
and I'm sure the same thing is not the
Boston Garden don't think that they're
[__] a miracle is [__] either
everywhere you know everywhere you know
uh when the [__] team comes to play
and yeah at the Boston uh
the garden
the baseball place anyway oh yeah Fenway
they only have six guys selling white
sock stuff but they got three guys
selling white stock stuff and that goes
in their [__] pocket you'd be
surprisingly yeah
yeah surprise how much little theft
there is that to you and me it's little
but at the end of the year it's
Monumental and I I forget what company
it was but I read a yeah
I read a story a while ago that somehow
this one guy figured out that if they
put one less Olive in every jar yeah it
would save them millions of dollars a
year so they just started putting in one
letter because no one's gonna say
anything who's counting you know if it
says 29 piece you're not counting
I can't even remember you whipped out
some olives to to you know for some
martinis you don't go hey we we got
robbed on one even if he does you go oh
we're missing one who cares and then
there's scams like I would guarant I
don't know the percentage but I would
guarantee a very large portion of
Apple's entire revenue is iTunes money
yeah it has to be that all they're doing
is selling the music and their computer
store
and and then [__] Airlines how many
billions of dollars are they making on
baggage fees just baggage fees not even
tickets
so let's say
this is stewardess there's a clerk
okay that she's figured out a way to
type in numbers
so that you don't have to pay for
baggage fees but she still charges you
yeah
I'm sure everything is very computerized
now but there's always a genius there is
people always find the floor that's not
even Geniuses like there's something
when I worked at TBS there was a button
called like non-taxable and you could
just put in a price if I was a thief I
could just put everything as one cent
and then take the cash if I knew what
the price was because it after a while
if someone buys a soda and you figure
out what tax it's 204 whatever you can
you need something bigger than that
obviously but you can figure out the
prices and just charge them whatever you
know I told you when Michael Bell was
here
that I worked at the car wash right yeah
like going home and going
like I'm robbing these guys legitimately
for six thousand a month that's just me
taking from them what about the partner
I got yeah she's Robin for six that's
twelve thousand a month
they're gonna be off a buck 30 next year
yeah and then I go what the [__] is
happening
or not or not yeah or not because maybe
we weren't the only people Robin I knew
we weren't the only people around there
yeah there was a guy around the back
that was Robin blind a black guy and his
brother that were detailers
they would detailing 10 cars and saying
they only had three yeah you know and
then anytime they're six off the top
anytime there's cash transactions and
it's like piece work like detailing and
and uh you know what about when you park
your car yeah the car Parkers all that
kind of stuff you figure out you could
take 100 a night right off the top yep
okay the other day I went to wash my car
it was funny because I had a bunch of
change in the middle when I got back in
the change was still there and I was
like you know what he could take a
quarter from memory card
yeah how do I know because I used to do
that right I used to be a car salesman
in Manhattan but I was doing comedy in
93.
that was nice I didn't have money to go
home
I would go into service
and go through the [__] cars yeah get
some change okay find [__] books I
would find tokens to get over the bridge
and those books to [__] with four
dollar books oh yeah and I would go
right to the bridge and sell them to
somebody hey there's 10 of them that's
40 bucks give me 20. yeah boom
yeah there's dudes at um in the Bay Area
uh Bart you know the subway there and
whenever you roll up man there's guys
that have some kind of bootleg cards and
stuff and they're like hey over here man
just give me a dollar and I'll give you
a round trip which is like nine dollars
you know this year they've got like
slider cards and and those other guys
that are running with the uh fake cards
for the gas pumps and stuff you know
they sell them to truckers and then
they're like just filling up their
trucks till the cards burn up you know
well what about the people I saw this
advice video about like the heroin uh
addicts in England are going and
stealing meat from all the grocery
stores and selling it boot like black
market just door-to-door yeah how crazy
just yeah why not it's like the copper
guys robbing those houses for all the
cars
I did all that shitly so I I I
understand
I get what it is to steal a steak from a
supermoon I live in Snowmass Village I
would go in there every night get a head
of lettuce and a
Oscar Mayer salami thing yeah but I
would steal a 10 [__] snake
in my back backpack I did it every night
yeah
and you know what adds up I feel guilty
for doing it today but I I did it it's a
[__] truth and I was doing blown I
wasn't doing blow those nights I just
know I could steal a steak for free and
some nights I got cock-assed old two
steaks yeah and something like I stole
two steaks on lobster tail for Jimmy
Burkle that's how crazy I got in there I
I get all this [__] and now in hindsight
you feel kind of bad in a way that I did
these things yeah when I worked at the
Randall Lumber oh my god when I was 15
16 17 I went to the lumber yard team
Delray what I did to these people was
brutal it was brutal I think back today
I paid for all those things brutal it
wasn't just it was 2 000 a week in
Lumber I was stealing from them you know
the sheets of plywood were 40 bucks 80
bucks I'm getting 25 a Chic give me 25
cash people coming in getting 20 sheets
from me on a Saturday
you know [__] installation uh this
what's this [__] called Thailand oh yeah
what they put on the walls yeah no the
other one uh
no the [__] that's designed oh like the
[__] linoleum and stuff that kind of
stuff on the walls yeah I used to sell
the four by eights people come in and go
down the last guy who was here would
charge me 30 a sheet [__] right back
here let's cut the [__] deal
you know that guy would come back there
and go I only made twenty thousand today
every bit is [__] empty yeah we used
to have uh plywood that was galvanized
so we could put it on boats marine
plywood it's called those would double
the money I would sell those for a
[__] in all the dough people would
just back up their [__] trucks and I
just go back there and help them load it
up they give me cash
yeah see you later [__] bye I
remember I used to have a gas key
and [__] a guy gave me a gasket this
is when gas went up to a like a dollar
for your five people like oh [__] it's a
dollar the old pumps before their
computer
they're just a
remember those and and then you know
when you put the pump away it turns it
off and it couldn't start again until
the guy came over with a key and turned
it and then it would reset and you could
pump gas so
we would one guy would just distract the
dude working at the station and then
you'd pump and then when he wasn't
looking he turned the key and pump again
turn the key and then you'd go up and go
all right five bucks but you had already
filled up like 25 you know whatever
because you could just turn it and reset
it it had the key forever man it just
people would be like you got that key
let me borrow it you know you'd have to
distract the dude one guy was a two-man
team
it's so crazy what the amount of theft
you know when people go to work
you know you were whatever and on your
company time you go on the computer
you're looking at porno and whacking off
in your cubicle that stuff right yeah
you know all those simple things a
[__] theft
you know and they add up they [__]
add up you know corporations are thieves
I mean I don't feel bad for them they
rob everybody American Airlines all
those [__] you know when you
call American Ambulance you're talking
to some poor [__] black chick who got
beat up last night and they got her in
there for the small 40 with no benefits
booking people to Jamaica and [__]
meanwhile this chick hasn't gone out of
the hood the whole [__] life you know
I'm only teasing you but you know when I
robbed when I was a kid and I robbed in
those businesses
okay like Lee goes criminals is smart
this [__] guy I worked for when I was
18. you rang up the [__] receipts and
then at the other night you zeed out
yeah you close the register you counted
the money you counted your bank out you
counted like I said eighteen hundred
dollars and you counted 1860 well you
made 60 bucks extra that one in your
pocket you put 1800 in the envelope you
put the [__] uh receipt in there
and you licked it and you put in a
[__] refrigerator
and you put the date on it that was it
tipped six I took the [__] tip money
that was mine whatever I made over on
the register was mine and it was that
simple well one man I'm doing blow in
the city
and I'm like where can I get some money
go wait a second I got the key to the
bar just go over there and steal one of
those envelopes so first I stole like
two I'm almost like the [__] Puerto
Rican that I am yeah and then
if they they said something to all the
bartenders some they stealing envelopes
running into the bottom of this
so I figured out a different way to do
it I just went and saw the envelope she
used and I went and bought boxes of
those envelopes yeah and I would go in
that night open up their envelope take
the new envelope put it in then take 100
off the top so whoever closed the night
before was sure the yard yeah you're off
a hundred [__] cruelty you know who
would think of that disgusting stuffily
I would yeah that's what drugs make you
throw everybody how to score [__]
money absolutely
drugs make you think like that because
you're like man this coke back then was
it was 350 an eight ball you know it was
it was 25 a quarter gram there's no
breakdowns unless you bought like an
ounce you know it was like 25 50 75 100
100 a gram 350 for uh an eight ball
three and a half grams so I mean that's
a lot of [__] money in the 70s and
80s you're like where am I going to get
that money
you know
do you think how much of it was it just
you are a good worker like have a good
work ethic and how much of it was
all those years drug stuff just you
really well you trained in hustling and
now you're just putting it towards like
actual business
it was a little bit of both my mom had
me working at an early age but even then
like I'm an early age I know how to flip
things yeah me too like I was doing
creepy things at like eight and nine you
know like like buying glue for sticky
Charlie and charging them 25 cents more
even though he was a junkie yeah you
know I tried the [__] that's not a
lie I have a story that's a true [__]
story I tried to sell this kid let's say
glue was a quarter or two I told him 50
[__] cents and try to shake them down
and most days I got this [__] loser
to give me a 50 [__] sense you know
we did [__] like that uh
I remember we sold bubble Young
they they when Bubble Yum first came out
it was unheard of and this one store
sold it miles away and we'd ride our
bike up there on Sunday and we'd buy
like 10 packs
for it was a quarter and then we'd sell
pieces at school a quarter a piece
because no one's seen Bubble Yum that
[__] was Next Level Square
unbelievable flavor delicious oh and it
was like a quarter piece we're making
money hand over fit and then for a while
Bubble Yum went off the market because
it said it had like red dye number five
in it or something and it was gone for
like a year I was like bubbly Yum's gone
what the [__] happened and then it came
back and by then it was in every store
but back in the day this one market had
it it was like a Chinese market had
Bubble Yum eighth grade I had a shop
right behind McKinley School where I
went to school and grammar school it was
uh that was my my grammar school's name
McKinley there was an embroidery Factory
a bridge and then there was this shop
right
and Shop right at an aisle just for gum
and they had Hubba Bubba yeah and bubble
yeah yeah and we used to steal a case
a Bubble Yum which is like 10 packages
in the case with in our pants and one of
us could get caught the other one would
run and we'd go back to the school and I
still remember sitting in the eighth
grade and Miss Walsh's class and all was
eating Bubble Yum and also somebody went
to the front of the class to write
something on the board people started
throwing pieces of bubble up at this
[__] right that [__] was good
right and it hit hard and it hit like it
was hitting the boy like that I'm a
genetic okay
this is the funniest thing ever clocked
them and some Richie Columbo was known
to be crazy was walking in from the
bathroom yeah and the gym is all night
to the face because the chat Richie goes
what happened to you on the channel goes
somebody hit me in the face with a piece
of gum making which he goes what flavor
was it
just walked away from the [__] guy oh
that's the dumb [__] in my [__] world
that I remember man remember they had
the next bubble gum that came out was
grape and that was gonna mix the flavors
up yeah next level people went to the
next level oh great I still remember
when that gum came out with the squirt
in your mouth oh for that freshen up
freshen up the person with green [__]
yeah once cinnamon came out you lost
your [__] mind dog dude that was the
[__] freshen up with that [__] jelly
in the middle that just got you fat as
[__] yeah it didn't do nothing to your
breath you still smell like Cheerios
just shot more sugar
you lose your [__] mind and that gum
will get your jaws tighter than [__]
Jack you talk you throw three pieces of
Bubba yum in your [__] mouth and
you'd be working that [__] jaw yeah
remember next was Big League Chew oh
that was awesome I need a whole [__]
when I was growing up there was a candy
store like an old wholesale Community
Avenue
they sold to other bodegas and stuff
like that but they had this thing called
devil gum it was way before
big red way before big red oh yeah this
was when cinnamon was still uncensored
you'd eat two pieces of this [__] and
your [__] face would turn red and
[__] oh it was so delicious
the gum was so delicious it was like
that gum from Clark yeah oh yeah I love
that [__] that [__] it's got some Clark
comes they still sell that though
they sell those things yeah and beaches
yeah yeah beaches and then that [__]
there has a texture it's [__] that
gum has a different texture like
Chiclets don't taste like that no more
chickens every time you go to the liquor
store it's always [__] hard now they
took the mini chickens off the market
which is the only reason I was going to
CVS I haven't boycotted them legally yet
I haven't gone on a national [__]
boycott yet they don't know it yet but
they used to have the little Chiclets in
the package I would buy four of them I
love that it's like yeah you eat the
[__] whole thing in one shot you're
spitting orange chickens the whole day
one sits behind your mola yeah next
thing you know you gotta go talk to the
dentist you got a little chicken behind
your [__] thing they took those off
the market the chickens are always hard
God forbid you gotta freshen up you need
10 jars a chick who sucked 100 dicks and
spring training to bust into that
[__] Walnut of gum I have these gums
and at these Hindu stores they're always
hard and the flavor goes away in one
second one [__] second what is that
you just chew it like for a minute and I
just spit it out
listen don't make nothing like they used
to no more yeah the [__] piece of gum
that's a flavor and you you chew that
[__] down to the stem
Lee what's going on you ready for
another star you're gonna sit there like
a mama look at me I'm good I don't think
I need another list yes you need a lot
of [__] things did you eat dinner
what'd you do today yeah what did I do
today I had a podcast with Johnny Rock
and uh
just worked out what worked here during
the day that's all the dog they're gonna
watch you like a [__] hook dude I
tell you the AC DC story talk to me
about AC DC what's going on all right so
yesterday I was uh on Sirius radio for a
couple hours so my phone was off and
when I came out one of my best friends
Billy Rowe from the band Jet Boy uh who
had a great record out in the 80s he
texted me and uh I'll read you the text
because it's uh it it threw me it threw
me for a loop and uh I still can't
believe it and a lot of people would
know but this was the text he hits me
with uh breaking news Brian Johnson
forced to cancel remaining AC DC shows
facing potential permanent hearing loss
the band is gonna make up shows with
special guest singer
so I was like what this can't be real
you know what I mean I just saw AC DC
three weeks ago Brian Johnson killing it
at the MGM me and Lucas hurl just down
there [__] rocking saw AC DC three
times this year every time Brian killing
it
so then I go to Rolling Stone they
announce it and uh boom that's it I go
to their website that's all it says I'm
like what the [__] then I start thinking
overnight I'm like this sounds kind of
funky
because they only have 10 Dates left on
the tour why would they even bother with
a guest singer after 36 years and uh you
know
why not just blow the dates out you're
billionaires
so then I start thinking about it and I
think wait a minute
I think like I think like Brian Johnson
quit or got fired or something and
they're just gonna carry on so today my
buddy says that he heard
that uh I'm gonna read it to you this is
insane uh Brian Johnson quit or was
forced to quit due to deafness
replacement is a guy uh name Jimmy
Barnes this is all uh uh you know
hearsay a guy named Jimmy Barnes a huge
guy from uh can you fire that up from
Australia uh singer older dude uh I
guess one of old AC this is all
allegedly you know I don't know what's
going on but it's uh like insane to me
to think that like at the end of this
incredible career AC DC's had that they
would just go let's put another guy in
there and just keep rolling that makes
no sense to me if your guy
let's say you and I are in a band for 36
years and then you go I can't hear
anymore
we did it you know and Malcolm's gone
Phil Rudd's out because of the the
crystal meth and the trying to kill hire
someone to kill someone
it's over it's over and it's the last
guy just say hey we we had a [__]
killer run
so it's just blowing my mind so I did a
full podcast today on it and websites
are already like talking about potential
singers because nobody really knows but
from what I'm hearing it's this Jimmy
Barnes guy it's crazy all right I went
to see bond with Ted Nugent yeah I went
to a lot of things and I believe in
evolution and stuff like that
Brian Johnson was great you know for me
but once I got into what I got into I
got into it yeah it didn't really after
For Those About The Rock We Salute You I
was pretty much done I saluted AC DC
yeah you know and I moved on and there's
some stuff I like
you know
it's like we spoke with Rudy these bands
are [__] great right now they're at
the BET like you said 36 years yeah and
what 10 years before that with Angus or
with Bond yeah like 10 years you know
that's 46 years of playing together
you're as tight as can be but you know I
don't know Brian's I don't even know I
don't even know and you're right at this
point just go away yeah just just go
away and when Brian Johnson gets better
and he could do three songs would do a
farewell show on TV which you guys are
billionaires anyway yeah who cares you
know it's like you know they
well how real do you think the the sound
loss thing is Dean I mean you played for
years well well my question is
this is all I thought about and and this
is just because this is my favorite band
of all time
in my mind I was thinking and this is
just my insanity
they did the new record uh a year ago
rocker bus so they worked on that record
a year before so they're two years in so
Brian Johnson 67. so maybe he goes in he
goes look I'm 65 right now let's do this
one Malcolm's out he's got dementia
we'll we'll [__] do the baseball
stadiums they sold 2.7 million tickets
this year uh only number two to Taylor
Swift they go we'll dude it's amazing
that's insane that's insane yeah how
many dates do you know roughly I don't
know but it wasn't a lot and you can
look that up so then they um I think
maybe they have a big meeting it's like
a corporation he goes look we'll just do
this run
and it'll be incredible we'll go out on
top with a record and a huge [__]
tour and now here it is it's been two
years almost and I think uh Angus was
like let's let's let's keep going and
maybe he went man what do you mean you
know we just let's just you know because
they dropped these dates out of nowhere
last month and people were surprised
like what are these dates hero and I win
we're like this is crazy they're playing
again I thought they were it was over
you know so maybe Angus was like we're
gonna do more dates all the way through
2017 or something he was like no man and
then maybe they just said all right well
uh you know we're gonna keep going and
like I saw a toy that just got announced
now when I saw it I didn't really react
to it but then I thought about it
throughout the day and I might disagree
to be
a [__] Kick-Ass show yeah oh this
could be a bust out and I guarantee it's
going to be a kick-ass Channel let me
guess the one hit me Def Leppard Arya
Speedwagon that one okay Bad Company oh
and Joe Walsh oh yeah right oh they're
playing like the Greek or something
that's gonna be oh [__] craziness Lee
like that that like that's like a slow
finger in the ass like people like ah
but there's some people that I'm going
oh [__] yeah let's go to that just bad
company alone if that guy could still
pipe it out yeah this guy could still
pipe it out and they could still play
like [__] so just that alone
never mind Joe Walsh comes out there and
does a few uh of his jams and then
starts doing maybe somebody shows up you
know from the Eagles you never [__]
know James gang stuff something there's
gonna this is this could be a dangerous
[__] show that you sit there and go
wow and then they all play together at
the end yeah we're gonna be sick no I'm
just saying that they did that yeah yeah
they came out and they just did like
feel like making love or an old free
song Like Fire and Water great things
out happening in [__] music yeah like
you look at the Hollywood Bowl schedule
it's phenomenal oh you look at the
Garden schedule it's for now there's
some great [__] bands and there's a
lot of stuff I don't know but you know
for you to be it just adds to somebody
today I was into serious Chris Cornell
is coming back yeah I saw that now when
is he coming I don't know they just
announced it yesterday yeah he's doing
like Santa Barbara Bowl that place is
great you ever go there no oh [__] it's
so weird you walk up through like a
neighborhood like it looks like you're
walking up to Runyon Canyon and you're
about to go hiking and you walk up like
a dirt road and you turn behind a guy's
backyard and it's this [__]
incredible Bowl that's been there since
like the 30s or something you know I saw
Black Crowes Oasis there unbelievable I
Saw My Morning Jacket there and it is
beautiful you got to look at that thing
online man it's a miniature miniature
Hollywood Bowl really small calling
badass but that's a great place to see
shows man it's worth the drive you go
out you see a band you get a hotel for
the night and chill in Santa Barbara
it's funny you said you went to Atomic
records yesterday yeah and I'm trying to
make it my weekly thing just so it's
like a hobby for me now like 3 30 I have
to pick the baby up at 5 30 so 3 30
gives me an hour over there I'll meet
you over there an hour to get home you
know I'm gonna put the albums away and
then I sit there and jerk off on the
albums that I bought pretty much you
know so once we got the new studio my
friend Damon gave me a turntable for
Christmas it's so great I said this is
the time this was my hobby when I was a
kid it brings me back a little bit even
my wife asked me when we walked out of
atomic today she goes I'm surprised you
don't go down there
and play more music I agree on with
these people in the daytime you know in
the building here yeah I have this on
full [__] speed ad all day long I'd
be down here with loud music smoking
bones that's your office man this is it
this is this is your back to basics
office [__] great so I made a list of
albums that I really wanted to get and
every time I go to email me but anywhere
else I couldn't find something like them
yeah and if I did find them they were
[__] off the charts expensive yeah
and not and not clean no I went to
Amazon yesterday Lee and I were on the
phone
and I went to Amazon yesterday to find
animals from Pink Floyd they want 79
bucks yeah you know for uh it's rare but
it's like like new for the 80 [__]
bucks and one part of me wants to pay it
but the other part of me is like Joe you
bought the sound for 7.95 I saw one
yesterday man for 25 I'll grab it for
you at freak what's it called freak this
is another great record store in Ventura
Boulevard uh in Sherman Oaks this place
all their records are phenomenal and
I've been going there uh since uh like
for years because they used to have like
here it is freak Beat Records and it's
crazy they got animals in there I saw it
uh 25 bucks and I've got two copies of
animals because it's so great I don't
wanna you know I don't wanna wear one
out that's my favorite man dogs
the whole album is [__] phenomenal so
I just wanted to get back into something
I wanted to get back into something that
was
real important to me yeah when I was
young and I tried to pitch a show call
beyond the sleeve but it's really tough
to pitch a music show yeah because you
have to reach out to the writers and all
these companies they would tell me about
a story with somebody at CAA got okay to
use somebody's song but then when they
really went to check the guy the song
was written by six people yeah so it was
like a [__] nightmare like in the
courts and petitions and like he doesn't
just stay away from music so the only
only other way we could do it is on the
podcast just to sit with a particular
album and whatever you know man I go
through music like you Dean every week I
got a new mind [__] yeah every make
something new inspires me yes that I'm
in the car I'm on [__] uh Magnolia
Boulevard waiting to go into the coffee
shop and outstanding comes on by the Gap
Band yeah and I'm gonna ship my pants I
haven't heard something that good in
[__] years like just that's a real
old school black music you think those
black [__] worried about
diversity in the Oscars they didn't give
a [__] now they were getting their dick
sucked they were smoking weed and they
were doing what they loved they didn't
care about that what the [__] are you
talking about [__] do what you love
and that overcomes the racism who gives
a [__] another guy going hey
oh when you're on the top oh no
I love about
it sometimes you have an idea
of what you're gonna talk about and
you're going through something else and
it's even stronger than one of the
positive yeah the message that you
wanted you know when I talked to Dean
this this morning we want to talk about
San Jose and music and the AC DC thing
which I didn't know were your favorite
band so I didn't mean to disrespect them
but you're not disrespected it's just
proper there's a point that that
you know like uh
Life music is [__] up once you get ego
involved in money oh you know I bet if
you go to every [__] musician
and go you know what if you could just
go back to the first day of making music
that feeling of being in the [__]
garage you know you know what's his
name's on on tour with uh
Peter Gabriel yeah yeah Stinger's on
tour Peter Gabriel it's coming to the
Bowl it's I want to go and assassinate
thing like that's the hate that I've
developed him over the years because you
could see his ego leaking out of his
pores I tried to watch him a few months
ago late night talk show yeah he came up
there with a ukulele you know and you
know like it's like you can I talk to
you for a second just because these
little homo friends that live next to
you in your neighborhood say that's cool
yeah that ain't cool I'm sure I'll be
able to [__] eucalypt I'll smack you
next time
[__] you guys and then he thought
like he went on tour with it you knew
about that so yeah smack him with the
ghostly those guys and he thinks like
well I'm gonna play something because my
friends told me and actually some people
go up them you know what kind of jerk
offs they go up to Yes man oh my God
that was the most brilliant thing no
one's not I didn't come here to see a
ukulele I came here to [__] see
synchronicity that's what I came here to
[__] hear okay not know you with a
ukulele and three little white dudes
that need testosterone shots on I don't
need this [__] and that's why he
aggravates me to no end to think that at
one time today I picked up one of their
Realms but it wasn't the one I won I got
a ghost in the machine I want a ghost in
the machine and synchronicity oh and the
first one this was something different
they didn't have what I was looking for
and it was funny that's what I thought
of I go what a [__] band that I was
in love with and they broke my heart yep
like it was like dating a woman that you
[__] don't listen man synchronicity
in 84. oh yeah took me from one
place to another uh
play wrapped around my fingerly oh man
that song
has always beaten me up emotionally and
physically like when I hear it five out
of ten times I'll switch it yeah the
other five times it's such a beautiful
Jam but it's such a a part of such a
beautiful album it's incredible it's a
[__] incredible one and I can't find
that either I gotta go down on me and
lift a rock and go for 30 now come with
me man come with me this weekend in San
Jose
let's just end the [__] aggravation
and just I do it with Marin we hit
records yeah
yeah but uh maybe Thursday yeah let me
see what happens tomorrow I got I got
hit with an audition it's like this
guy's tremendous yeah this guy's really
good but I'm not going it's a Disney
thing for a [__] Mexican sheriff in a
Mexican town that don't look like
me-headedly watch this [__] this is
brilliant this was this was something
that [__] killed me like did they
break up after they sound this ain't
Italy it's The Police Wrapped Around
Your Finger yeah by the police you're
killing me you know what one kills me
walking on the moon that one Giant Steps
we [__] played that on the show Once
oh I must have got 50 emails and I was
making shocked that people had not heard
this before it's a [__] crazy no it
was synchronicity that last out yeah
awesome yeah yeah yeah that was it yeah
and then they got back together about
five years ago remember six years ago
and did a tour and uh then they imploded
again
V MTV was God this was just something
put on uh what's the one you saw
watching walking on the moon Jesus
Christ we opened up with that Lee Lee
the time we opened up with that I must
have got no exaggeration the next day 25
emails
what album is that on and who was that
wow and I was in shock I was like you
mean to tell me you don't know this
piece of History there's only four
[__] albums I think or five albums
yeah and you don't know this this is a a
just a Monster version no see if they no
no hit that record version right there
just some shout outs here I'm gonna
close up this section here uh first
shout out I want to give out this Daniel
Cameron Corin he's the one that said you
got to bring music back on the [__]
podcast I thank you brother because your
comment was the one that pushed me over
the top my main man alibaz Scott
Phillips Alex zapate Enrique Rivera Tim
glob Seven Ten Raven good Robert Sochi
Clint oldie and green Cloud I love you
[__] thank you for always
supporting us here what I wanted to get
to tonight was an album that got
released
on July of 1981.
I had gone to see Def Leppard
either open up for priest yeah or Iron
Maiden it was Iron Maiden opened up for
priests but I saw Def Leppard on the on
through the night tour I didn't see him
then
which was
which was 80 right okay and then
I saw it I saw a Death Leopard Judas
Priest No oh I saw them open up for AC
DC oh wow August 4th 79 80 80. oh Back
in Black tour second show second night
they opened up in Philadelphia wow and
the second night was at the Palladium in
New York City
and they were tremendous and Angus was
terminal yeah the whole night was
tremendous
but I remember going home like in those
days in my world you didn't go see the
old man yeah yeah that's right you're
correct they got booed off
and my world he didn't go to the opening
act and in my world there was actually
great opening acts you know the one that
they said everybody said you had to go
see was when they said go see Black
Sabbath the dudes in front of them
tremendous guitar player but the word
out was this deaf leopard had opened up
for somebody year before and people like
Def Leppard's opening up from you gotta
go and I went and they played
Mirror Mirror oh yeah
I'm going home and there was no computer
in those [__] days Lee yeah and they
wouldn't tell you afterwards the name of
that song is mirror mirror it's off to
whatever album so I had to go and buy
the [__] album and when I put on this
album
it destroyed me you know just uh
until this day when I put on this album
yeah I think about a certain period in
my life because the album came out in
July of 81. I finally picked it up like
December of 81. it came alive
people were talking about songs you go
to parties by February people were
putting this [__] album this album
was and by
April and May of that year when I was a
senior in high school no matter whose
car you went into yeah they had high and
dry yeah that's how we played this
league on the turntable or do we play it
on YouTube
I think YouTube For Better YouTube would
be better in here but if you wanted to
crank it on that I wouldn't blame you
would you we should do YouTube yeah yeah
let's do YouTube for them you know I
don't know if that I don't know if you
let's see let me look at the record is
that the most important so yeah so
what's on what song do you want to play
off of it I want to play Mirror Mirror
okay
oh ladies trains take a look at this
album cover no I don't know if anybody's
here but the the first first of all the
most crazy thing about this record
incredible album cover the art you know
the guy's diving into an empty pool but
on the back I believe they're just
around 18 and 19 at this era so this is
the singer but this was a guy Pete
Willis who to me was the king of the
band he played a hammer Explorer and he
was absolutely crushing you've got Steve
Clark who later died from alcohol and
then you got Rick Allen who lost an arm
and a crash has been a crazy curse and
then you've got the bass player uh
Savage Rick Savage and then of course
Joe Elliott but this is the original
lineup and they're from Sheffield
England and I went to Sheffield one time
and I couldn't believe it Sheffield's an
old steel town like Detroit and alls I
kept thinking was how did this [__]
band get out of Sheffield and into
America it's unbelievable to think
they're kids man they're [__] kids
they lived at their mom's houses and
[__] and this and it's all about the
tunes on this it's so [__] raw and
radical and they sound like you know
they they sound unbelievable it was way
different band than they are later on
Pyromania and hysteria and even now this
sound has always been like a I don't
know whenever I hear this album I just
think of fun times with my friends
that's it people looking for me stealing
yeah no worries
with my friends no worries no worries
and this song this album was you know
like the [__] uh
I don't know what to call it like the
the staple for that summer it's the high
water mark man it was it really was and
it really was those Jensen tri-axles and
a Camaro that speaker that was out right
around this time with the [__] auto
reverse cassette players finally it play
the whole thing and flip it on its own
you know what I mean it's very funny
because
July of 82 I robbed this dude right yeah
whatever his name is is not important
the scam was I used to bring them stolen
TVs and he always give me a gram of blow
right just one night we were going to
see Ozzy without Randy Rhoads with uh
the guy Brad Gillis with Brad Gillis at
The Meadowlands and I got a friend of
Tron fan in the box and he got all cocky
on me he said I'm not giving you the
[__] uh
I'm not giving you the [__] gram of
blow
so you know and typical Joey Diaz style
I got [__] furious and I vowed I was
gonna get this [__] it took me
10 months to go yeah but I got him
and even after he [__] me I'd go over
there and buy Blow from him and have
conversations and he was funny but I
knew eventually I was in a cash in my
chip with this guy yeah and I finally
got him in July of 82. when did [__]
Rick when did Randy Rhodes die he died I
think in 1882 81-82 uh look it up yeah
look it up
side two you want Joey
82 in Florida right Randy Rhodes died in
82. oh in two days is the anniversary
wow
March 10th yeah wow wow we'll celebrate
it up there yeah man so uh
this guy had beat me and I waited 10 or
11 months to nail this [__] and
one that I nailed this [__] on a
Friday night yeah with this dude I made
a mistake and I nailed this guy with a
dude it was a rat
it was too late when I put two into the
gather when I went to give them half the
coat and he goes no no I saw yours I'm
never gonna say nothing I go God damn it
oh oh
you knew I started snorting when I'm
snorting when I'm snorting with him and
then right away he had to go home he had
a curfew
so
that doesn't make a long story short we
snorted coke that whole weekend
and my friend that we had out for two
nights he had to go to summer school
that Monday morning
and he was out with us since Saturday
night we had him I mean Saturday
straight 18 years old we hooked up on a
Saturday night I robbed the guy on a
Friday we stayed out all night till six
in the morning drove down the shore and
back I was in bed by in the afternoon I
got up at four eight did what I had to
do I wasn't gonna go out about 10 30 my
little Goombas called me and we went out
and we stayed out from Saturday storm
Coke all day Sunday
the Sunday morning Monday morning
this is two nights of snorting coke and
there's still a bucket left of it if I
Rob from this guy and we're selling
little deals to people Dean come here
yeah ding you want an eight ball for
250. get the [__] out of here eight
balls at 300 look at the look look what
I'm gonna do for you yeah yeah okay
remember me kind of sucking when you're
a junkie you remember oh [__] so I was
just picking up hundreds from friends I
knew just to Keep Us Alive for a couple
days but that Monday morning he can't go
to summer school he's already got two
misses so we gotta go see a teacher I
know Mr T and we gotta clean this [__]
up so we knocked on T's door he sees us
he's like what are you [__] crazy
you're all coked up but the moral of the
story is we're driving
he knew we had blow here we are 18 years
old we just graduated high school T gets
in the car with us he does two lines of
coke and he's like what the [__] is
going on I like it I love figures in the
background yeah cool woman cool eyes
get ready
I mean read the songs out to them and
tell them break the songs okay all right
well first of all that's one of the
greatest intros of rock let it go you
know and then it just tells you the mood
yeah it just tells you what you're going
to get involved into which a lot of
people don't [__] do no more all
right the second song is Lady strange
nope another hit and run another hit and
run tremendous again oh yeah next one
high and dry Jesus Joseph and Mary
motion then bring it on the Heartbreak
oh [__] the big ballot then switch uh
625 which is like an instrumental and
then uh you go to side two
you got uh Bring It On the Heartbreak uh
you know uh oh this is a remix on here
then you got me running you got me
running you got me running remember that
one oh just [__] give me the songs
that lady strange lady strange yeah yeah
on through the night
Mirror Mirror look into my eyes remember
that hit it Lee little mirror mirror
yeah
it's too much this Jam is too [__]
much oh it's so good I can't tell you
how many [__] lines and eight balls
of blow I did to this gym wrote these
songs no one wrote these songs for him
it's an American Idol and [__] these
guys were in a garage and slugged out
these [__] tunes that are Classics
right now that people go crazy over I
mean you know that high and dry song a
band would die to have a tune like that
right now you know just one of those and
they got like nine killers on there
eight killers on there you know and they
wrote those at [__] like 17 18 19 20
years old it's insane to me
it's insane and the singing his singing
is so great for like 20 years old he's
not like oh yeah yeah you know it just
sounds incredible
this is a masterpiece yeah and the one
afterward you know uh the one before
this was great yep it wasn't Sensational
like uh you know but it was a good album
for the first time I like wasted I love
wasted but this one here [__] me up
completely I mean I fell in love with
this album for maybe three four years
and whenever I hear different songs now
they never played mirror on the radio no
they always play bringing on the [__]
Harley drives me crazy now uh who are
the people around them on the back of
the that's just artwork they're just
cousins of yours
that's it it's just you know in those
days yesterday we were reading about I
called Lee and I told the Wikipedia wish
you were here and I go look at the
preparation they put into the packaging
yeah like they put as much like they
were talking about they took pictures to
signify the agents that they're greedy
they sell their soul they got them
Lighting on fire on the Warner Brothers
lot you know they just Pink Floyd put as
much thought into the [__] uh album
as as just to [__] with people turn that
around you said something yeah the guy's
gonna dive into an empty pool yeah you
know how many times you look at that and
you're like what does this mean is he
getting hung upside down why is he high
and [__] dry
it's this I mean this kind of artwork
right here I would love to just have in
my house hanging you know because it's
something it's very
um you know it's almost kind of looks
like old uh like craft work kind of
artwork you know that band craft work
just it's just really crazy like what is
this which is even cooler when you're a
kid you're just looking at it going what
does that mean you know I know that was
me at two in the morning with you know
on a quaalude would blow looking at this
going why are they looking up and he's
jumping down in the logo they never
change the logo it's spectacular from
day one they got a [__] crushing logo
really is a different world for music
yeah how much thought and because they
wanted you to stop and buy this that's
right that's right they wanted you to
walk by and [__] buy this and and
they had to be a decision all five
members of the [__] band look at this
you know we were talking about this
right here look at where do you want me
to look read this go all the way down
scroll down
to uh whatever the [__] keep going
packaging yes packaging you know wish
you were here
I'm gonna get my glasses on
oh wow look at that uh they had the dude
he he went out on tour with him in 74.
Scott Jorgensen storm Jorgensen yep had
a company the band The 74 20 meeting of
the lyrics eventually deciding that the
songs were in general concerned with
unfiltered presence rather than
Barnett's Barrett's illness this theme
of absence was reflected in the ideas
produced by the long hours spent
brainstorming with the bands blah blah
blah blah blah blah
uh cell phone Jorgensen had noted that
the Roxy Muse's country life was sold in
an opaque green
cellophane sleeves censoring the cover
image and he copied the idea concealing
the artwork I wish you were here in a
black colored shrink wrap therefore
making the album art absent the concept
behind welcome to the machine and we
have it here with the bag that's killer
well the guys were actually on film
right here you walked by this yeah and
you got a black [__] bag that's it
and the concept was behind the welcome
to the machine and having cigars you
have to do that the use of a handshake
or often an empty gesture and Gordy
Hardy designed the sticker containing
the album's logo on two mechanical hands
right there yeah [__] genius yeah
[__] genius man
uh mechanical handshake logo would also
appear on the labels of the vinyl Helm
this time in black and blue blacker the
album's cover image was inspired by the
idea that people tend to conceal their
true feelings for the fear of getting
burned and thus the two businessmen were
picture shaking hands One Man on Fire
getting burned is a common phrase in the
music industry often used by artists who
are denied royalty payments two stunt
men we use I mean you know the
photograph was taken on the Warner
Brothers lot in Los Angeles
initially the wind was blowing the wrong
direction the Flames were forcing to run
those fights burning his mustache how
[__] crazy is that I know right I
didn't even know it was real guys on
fire yeah I just thought it was dead
yeah this is this is guys this is the
thought it was a complete different
situation you know that's why I think
even like when I did the CDs with Lee I
always [__] thought about something
you know I snuck them to a church with
Felicia and took pictures you know this
time I [__] walked at my daughter
because I wanted the album cover to
reflect what I was thinking at that time
I don't know who the [__] I was and a
kind of a joke in a way you know what
I'm saying I am Catholic what are you
gonna do but we don't get that no more
now all I got to do is go on iTunes
click a thing and I got an email saying
we took 299 out of your [__] account
yeah and uh Sail Out V you don't get a
letter you don't get a picture you don't
get a handshake you don't get a history
behind that joke nope you don't get who
gots so it just shows you why sometimes
these musicians get pissed about that
money because they put a lot of extra
work into this which like New Wave are
probably charging them
hundreds of thousands like the guy
designed that logo what do you think
they charged up left it to design that
logo a lot ten thousand yeah yeah ten
thousand sure mate yeah you know they
weren't rich but they thought they were
going to get rich yep
and the logo lasted for [__] ever oh
yeah I I had uh I had the guy on
um that wrote this uh AC DC book called
uh the brothers Young
the guys that built AC DC and they there
was just a guy who worked at Atlantic
like an intern or something in the art
Department that Drew their logo right he
didn't get any money he was just an
intern an AC DC has been using that logo
for [__] 50 years on shirts and
garbage cans and bumper stickers and
lighters and [__] beers and
everything that [__] logo you know
they got it free it's crazy right
it's just uh I don't know where the
artwork and music went yeah and it's
something that people have heard me talk
about before but it still baffles me
because it's such a this is what the
music is go in there you know when I
look at a picture I just look at a
picture and this with music they made
you look at the picture and then go in
it
let's go in the picture and get the
album and let's play it the other room
you know because we don't want my mom to
hear it you know it's uh it's just a big
part of my life I wish
we could find a way to do a show we
could do this on a weekly
basis without the fear of getting sued
or [__] getting hung by our balls
because
I think that this is missing from a lot
of people's lives you know this is this
could put your life together if you're
on blow and you get out of a rehab and
you go you know what what did I do as a
child I had 300 albums what I do with my
phone for 10 bucks when I got hooked on
coke let me go build my thing up again
make little notes and as stupid as it is
it's just you like music anyway I like
music man yeah I can't you want to throw
me in jail throw me in jail you want to
really [__] me up take away my music
yeah what about local access
can you do it there or no
what play music I don't know I gotta
find that that's why I love doing this
podcast really because it's like
there's very few people that can really
really [__] talk to music about it's
like you Marin Burr
um
we all love music and we're just [__]
I think it's the arrow we just grew up
in it just it just ran parallel with our
Insanity do me a favor missing persons
mental Hopscotch no the other day I'm
scrolling and I see this on YouTube oh
yeah and I and all of a sudden it's like
getting smacked in the [__] face
mental Hops uh Missing Persons in an
album called destination m whatever the
[__] it was yeah but before they
released destination then they did what
everybody else did in the business they
released an EP and I'm that EP was a
song called mental hopscots that to me
was one of their best songs he couldn't
sing in real life she couldn't do
[__] Dick Dale yeah now that you look
the husband can play the [__] out of the
drunk Crusher but I thought I was
watching blazio I started I got hooked
on
you know Frank's garage oh yeah all the
Frank Zappos [__] yeah and then after
this was on the plane yeah and then
after Zappa I got hooked on something
else that was so obscure again I hadn't
heard in years but you don't have enough
time to listen to music that's the
problem yeah I don't have with the child
and the podcast you know listen to music
you have to put the album on roll a
joint put the earphones on bang it and
you need an hour and a half at least one
day [__] you know one hour I love all
that [__] but I live on 15 minutes play
this [__] when we listen to this [__]
every once in a while you gotta go off
the deep end and just talk music man
like I said people should do this more
we just don't have the time a lot of
people don't even love this [__] you
know you got to really be into this [__]
to really don't know what the [__] we're
talking about he's looking at me all
scared I get the most tweets when I do
this show sure because we talk about
music and then just like man I love when
you guys talk about music I mean the
Twitter is on fire over it I picked up
an album today by mistake that I did not
go to the store even looking for
Marin when I shot Maron a couple weeks
ago he told me he went on a Saturday
and he picked the sister up to this
album which is cars candy oh oh God act
which is brilliant yeah that's another
82 81 type out Crush no 79 yeah 79 but
my freshman year in high school an album
came out that was [__] just
superb [__] superb oh oh the cars
dude
unbelievable that man
there you go
oh
that [__] first album oh like listen
man it was Ted Nugent it was Black
Sabbath it was AC DC it was all this
stuff at the same time I'm getting into
this just let me get that album cover
over there at the same time
I'm getting into this uh a buddy of mine
gives me a
what the [__] did he give me he gave me
like one of this albums yeah he's like
y'all listen to this and at first
I didn't know what the [__] they were
talking about yeah I'll tell you I think
the biggest one
I don't know if it's the the biggest
mistake they made or who the [__]
mind
I'm talking about people's mistakes
[Music]
foreign